s truly can I see that no we're just
drinking saler can I see it sure
man well you got it all over your butt
it's okay
ma'am do you guys have your IDs on you
no ma'am sorry okay how old are you uh
okay
perfect do you have anything on you
cougar card no ma'am ma' okay just my
phone sorry ma'am all
right
[Music]
you're not lying to me are you no ma'am
ma'am okay so why are you hiding the
white claw then I put it behind because
I thought she was it just bad ma'am and
also okay what's your last name
uh con how do you spell it c a a
n
okay c a a n c a a n okay and first
name
Dan D N ma'am okay and what's your
birthday September
21st
1993 93 okay so how old does that make
you 22 ma'am okay and what's your
address here in Pullman I don't live in
pman ma'am okay where do you live at
Alabama okay what's your address in
Alabama
1834 wild Court Wild Flower Court
M and what's the zip code in
Alabama
[Music]
uh 6352 1 635
21 okay and what city in
Alabama uh SP Sport Alabama man Spanish
Fort okay and do you have a driver's
light license through Alabama yes ma'am
okay what's your middle
initial
Michael
okay pman 4
for9 I'm going to help you out here go
ahead you're telling a story yes sir
name through Alabama if you the force
you can get this return is going to say
you're not a person and we take you to
pman okay Charles
ad David ad Mary
through Alabama entered into a program
through the prosecutor's office which
called deferment program or Divergence
program I don't know the name or if you
don't tell this officer before she gets
the fact that there's no return on that
that you lied to her about her name your
name we're going to take you to P sir
I'm going to be honest I don't need to
be entered into a program I'm sorry I
just so if you're okay I'm just telling
you if you're lying we're going to take
you to PO I'm not leaving you okay
please leave I'm not no she she's not
free to leave either oh yes ma'am I'm
sorry
fine my name is Sophia cash
I I promise I don't need SP turn into a
program I don't drink every day this is
okay what's your middle initial
Sophia and what's your real birthday
April 11th
2000 and what's your address here in
pulman I actually don't know that but I
live in Orton what room
number and your phone
number' and that's through Alabama uh
that's actually through Olympia
Washington my parents moved after no do
you have a driver's license through
Alabama I do but I don't know
thec Coleman 449 let's check a different
name L of cash Charles Adam Sam Henry
first Sophia Sam ocean Paul Henry Ida
Adam middle P Paul
Alabama uh February 121 221 Y where do
you live I live
in 1131 excuse me and how did you spell
your last name uh
money okay so you're under arrest for
minor in possession of alcohol and
making FAL from misleading
statement I please just just go
it's my
phone did you
nope just go just I'll explain to you
what's going on perfect 100% is there
can I just ask a question pick
up police department sorry ma'am Forman
Police Department so you have the right
to silent anything you see can will be
used against you in the court of law you
have the right at this time to an
attorney have him present for during any
questioning or the making of statement
if you can add for one one will be
appointed to you at no cost you're being
audio and Visually recorded it is
September
21st 2019 and it is 2340 hours yes
ma'am okay so we're going to go to the
passenger side of my car
phone I'm
sorry glass on my head I can't see very
well with I'm on okay do you have
anything on you that's going to poke
stab or hurt me uh I think you took my
pocket knif first I think the officer
over there took my pocket knife it was
in my front pocket my front right pocket
male and female yep there's no knife
there excuse me
sir male or
female all right go ahead no you're good
all right go sorry ma'am okay
there's no Christians back here nope
there is not that's for people 99 left
me so that's for people because they
either pee themselves or they puke a lot
honestly that makes a lot of sense I
will warn you ma'am I do get
claustrophobic okay well it shouldn't
take too long all right all right ma'am
thank you just know it's about a 5
minute drive down toing facil sounds
good thank you ma'am
um go
ahead far away so I'm going to confirm
and then be right back with
you give her the warning yep she is good
she was not uh a problem for
me you got no I did yeah no I mean the
knife no I'm just trying to get this
thing time it is over there so uh so you
are just going to get a warning okay so
we'll enter into our system you were
warn for Min the effect
you admit to having a little bit okay um
so that just means though from now on
until you turn 21 if you get contacted
again you will get arrested or sighted
or something there will be an
escalation okay so you have a good
night has drink I knew she was going to
lie to me a second she opened her mouth
so thank you so much for everything I'm
so sorry for inconvenience it's fine do
you mind just throwing this away for me
100% I'll throw in bed thank you so
much thanks
Shane
pull in
49 transporting one adult female to a
holding good
spot I thought about not getting out too
but
what's
Sophia hey Sophia yes sir so I just want
to give you an update on your friend
okay uh which friend sir the uh the
black female you were with okay sir I
can't pronounce her name yes sir so she
was just giving a warning okay let me
tell you why she was just giving a
warning yes sir because she didn't she
didn't tell stories yes sir Okay and
like like I told you you would have just
got a warning too but you wanted to kind
of play games yes sir
so okay but you still have your lap belt
on yes sir do you feel secure with
officer Dylan's driving yes sir me too
it's very good I just wanted yeah no I
appreciate it I heard the I heard the
seat Bel and I I thought my goodness did
she take it off how did she do that but
I guess it just fell so
okay so maybe in the future if you could
go go back in time how would you have
handled this situation well sir I
probably would have just told Tru start
probably oh
no okay I don't want to get my friends
in trouble yeah but I don't know how you
telling a fib would uh get your friends
in trouble it's only going to get you in
trouble honestly sir I'm I'm not really
sure either yeah probably cuz you've
been drinking quite a bit I haven't been
drink a bit just more than a little bit
more than a little bit somewhere in
between there somewhere yeah those white
claws will get
you yeah it's been a tough week
it
mhm what was in the
flask uh I didn't have a flk no but you
did though cuz officer Dylan got the
flask off of
you see here's the
problem Captain Morgan gave it to you or
that's what was in it no I think Captain
was okay
no I doubt it he's I think he was a
pirate so see you already are you told
me you were going to be honest but now
he told me you didn't have a flask but
then you did so you told me another FIB
I don't know what to do here sir I'm
sorry I really I'm having a hard time
remembering okay why do you think you're
having a hard time remembering probably
because I drink a little too much a
little too much is that Captain was the
flask empty when you got it yes sir oh
it was so you just carried around an
empty flask on you I think so sir you
think so yes is it honestly I'm reping I
understand Miss cat now it's probably
more likely though that you probably
drank something that was in the flask
honestly sir I don't think I drank out
of the FL I think I might have
I but you got it
bag okay but then then what did you just
have the white claws uh I do not have
any white claw
but there was a wasn't there a white
claw can behind you that you hid cuz you
didn't want to get your friends in
trouble her friend hid it behind her oh
your friend hit
it well you know what they say there
ain't no laws when you're drinking claws
but unfortunately that is not true that
is the internet has let you
[Music]
Downton whether you have the white claw
or not
yeah it's true I've read the US and
Washington Constitution and they don't
even mention white claws in there I
think it's cuz they're relatively new
yeah probably I don't think Thomas
Jefferson was drinking the white I
honestly have a hard time piing maybe
some version of it though I have been
more drinking like an old fashioned mhm
mhm what were you drinking tonight uh
tonight sir I was drinking a v Sprite
but it was not the fault of the people
that were there I drinking it all my own
okay and that's not what was in the
flask
okay uh sir do you like
Tom is that what's playing right now yes
yeah I enjoy this song it's pretty good
I
was
yeah I mean this is a good song it it's
classic look at that car it's miror
that's very weird it's automatic though
well I almost a pedestrian why would
that be
automatic my truck has a button that I
go Boop and it like folds them in and
then I hit the button again and it folds
them back out even when you're driving
yeah if even if I'm driving I can put
the mirrors
in what do you mean are you in
nope how does
it good been done for like three years
now Robert Ocean Frank
Frank Tom idy ocean Tom Henry young
little initial C Charles
0916 70 May
California
like yeah I
do yeah that's the popular one pman 449
EG kill man I
know oh oh who's this well this is we'll
just we'll just walk her
in just parking this a second spot here
the
old now miss cash we're going to walk
you in okay so don't try to run away
okay cuz if you run as good as you tell
the truth we'll catch you pretty
easy leaving the knife in the
car
yeah cuz I'll take it around and give it
to I'm a little done but I'm not
that can I get
yep excuse me follow my a little bit
okay so just go ahead and follow
him watch there there's a little bit of
yes sir I'm
okay
all right go ahead and walk on
through go stand by the orange cone up
there okay
so how do you get this key off you um
it's just like a basic d-ring or not a
d-ring but like one of
the separate
yeah pretty much whatever you want to
call it one of those
ma'am perfect got
it um I think there in my back and
pocket but also I think I lost my phone
so there might not there's chapstick up
here I think that's it I think uh sir
and your CER car that you said you have
did you take my uh sorry sir yeah your
knife is in my car
yeah yeah you will okay so go ahead and
turn
[Music]
around my no come
okay
okay go and have a seat in that brown
chair on the other side there grab some
paperwork you want to grab it
no no I did not you want to get the
knife I'll get
this
okay pull in 449 case number in custody
time
I look at that stuck in my head it
happens I got tiny danc stuck in my head
right now for that's what I got wait no
not
true do you live in pulman sir uh I do
not do you live in CA I do not Moscow I
do not wow really I find that very
surprising yeah I'm just not going to
tell you where I live that's fine I I
respect that s
I was just wondering for C like honestly
just on pure curiosity I'm looking for
an apartment right now for next year sir
well I get one in Pullman cuz you don't
want to drive anywhere okay okay that
makes
sense okay last name is c c H like money
first name Sophia s o p h i a middle
initial P date of birth uh April 11 2000
sir
okay and you live in what Hall Borton
sir what
d
phone
number where were you born feville North
Carolina feville yes spell that uh f a y
e t t e v i l l a e sorry sir North
Carolina North Carolina how tall are you
54 how much do you
what
130 eye color blue iner is
blonde really Brown sir what do you call
it depends on the day honestly it's
naturally brown then yes sir
okay
what do you
know
key is should have been on my belt too
yeah okay I put things in value so I
don't put the Chapstick down there's
[Music]
no okay your
property sign right there oh and I need
your shoes and if you're wearing a belt
your belt not wearing a belt but I am
wearing
shoes do you do you need my socks as
well sir nope put your shoes in this box
please
sry anything I need that officer missed
oh I need the necklace any additional I
actually have two necklac okay two
necklaces I'll verify that and write it
down and then are you wearing earrings
uh yes okay four on each side sir do I
have to take those
out I know damn it I wish I wouldn't
have there I'm sorry all right
um sir I'm actually having trouble
getting this off I'm going to be honest
okay well keep keep trying you'll get
it are you wearing a watcher bracelet uh
no sir
okay I'm not wearing like anklets or to
Rings or anything like that
either I'm just going to tie this back
this coming in the way that's fine so
just sign here I'm not going to steal
your shit so it's all on camera just
sign right there it'll be in your
property when you I don't know how much
would be worth anything either so sign
right there I'm going to leave because I
got to put some stuff away and then
while you are doing that work on
removing
youres oh was at the flask oh my God I
do I'm so sorry look at this property on
there that you didn't even know you I
know I am so sorry sir okay so work on
taking off the necklaces and the
earrings yes sir and I'll be back with
you earrings off perfect them all off
perfect she's got to take her necklace
and stuff off I just don't want to be in
there she's fine in there we put people
in there who are drunk so she's all
right where did you start from are we
just doing
exhibiting
what time did you start should we put
her in a different
cell should we put her in a different
cell well I know but you said we can
just leave her in there we oh okay
that's what I was confused I was like I
just
[Music]
didn't it's just such a
small are
these I have this one
what ones are open the ones at the end
so what were you
[Music]
jumping I didn't realize we had a lot of
people in
here all right did you get your necklace
off uh I did get my necklaces off but
not my earing ma'
okay but both of my necklaces are on the
desk okay I'll take the necklaces your
earrings are probably okay okay so just
are you sure' yep
okay okay all right so come with
us
okay we're going to put you over in
here okay so you're going to be in here
for a couple hours at least until you
sober up a little bit and your necklaces
will be in this glove so it not get lost
did you need my earrings or not your
earrings are fine thank
you
more
hopefully the fuck is that
snow my goodness she sh
herself somebody's having a worse night
than you well I'm actually kind of glad
to hear that okay you're all done with
her okay so this is your Citation for
minor in possession of alcohol and
making false or misleading statements to
a public servant um you should get
something in the mail within 15 days
telling you when your court date is if
you you don't get something in the mail
uh telling you when your court date is
make sure you give the court here a call
and ask them when your court date is
okay um I've never done this so
I'm so the prosecutor will give you a
call and basically kind of tell you
what's up okay um or that document that
I cannot get you have to like lift okay
my friend gave me that you have to like
lift that silver piece and turn it at
the same time it's like jammed down it's
a little I think I broke it it's
okay anyway I think did I not have like
a blue Columbia fleece when you guys Pi
no you didn't have a phone either yeah
so lost I was looking I for that so I'm
cool with giving this back to you um it
still has some alcohol in it so make
sure um you rinse it so that way you
don't get arrested for it again okay
great thank you um just sign here saying
I'm giving you all your stuff back all
you had on you was a key some sunglasses
um ID your necklaces are in this glove
okay and then your shoes thank
you so yeah next time don't tell me your
name is
Dan could have at least thought of a
girl name I know I'm really sorry I was
like that's an interesting name to go
with you're like really that's what
you're going to that's you're going to
stick with is like
okay yeah I'm really sorry that's all
right as long as you learn from it all
right yep definitely we'll be doing this
again cuz not going to lie I mean he
does have a very nice station but that's
not I don't know it's probably cold in
there it was a little cold so you can
put all your stuff back on oh you had a
[Applause]
ChapStick I can't open this I don't know
it looked like he stole them from a year
old yeah those were given to me by
someone and I was tolded to wear them so
I got I believe somebody's outside
waiting for you yay
great um I'm sorry what time is
it 3:30
3:16 at least it's Satur well Sunday I
guess technically so you can sleep in
that is
true all right and then you have a a
knife as well that we took off you but
you but uh when you go out to the lobby
it'll be at that front desk and she'll
hand it to you when you get out in the
lobby okay great thank you just cuz we
can't have any weapons in here so yeah
sorry about that so this is yours to
keep uh you'll get something in the mail
at uh lim or Orton Hall which
is if for some reason they mix up that
address and it doesn't get to you just
make sure you call them if you haven't
gotten anything within 15 days okay okay
okay all right so if you just push
through this door here and then push
through the second door it takes you
right to the lobby uh grab your knife
and then you're free to leave okay right
thank you very much have a nice night
thank
you